pour en parler nous sommes avec mathieu
bolle reddat secrétaire du syndicat cgt
cheminots de versailles bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation alors
vous êtes toujours mobilisés malgré
justement la ligne de conduite du
gouvernement de l'exécutif concernant
cette réforme des retraites et à la
ligne de conduite comme vous dites ligne
de front en ligne de fracture ligne 2
ligne de violence on le voit y compris
vis-à-vis des grévistes ce qui s'est
passé hier notamment vis-à-vis des
éboueurs des égoutiers des travailleurs
des incinérateurs de paris avec le
gouvernement via le préfet l'allemand
qui prétend réquisitionner les grévistes
donc quand on fait acte d'autant de
violence et de brutalité c'est que on
n'est pas forcément tranquille pas
forcément ferme sur ses appuis voilà
donc bah lui continue à avancer comme un
bulldozer et ben nous on va continuer à
se mobiliser
le texte du gouvernement il
il a débuté son parcours au sein du
parlement il est à l'examen en ce moment
par une commission spéciale
il ya beaucoup d'amendements 22 mille
amendements à doivent être étudiées par
rapport à cela la position aujourd'hui
des syndicats bapt est évidemment que
nous notre jeu c'est pas le jeu
politique au sens politicien du terme à
l'assemblée à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat
ce qu'on observe quand même c'est que il
ya eu retoquage très très violent quant
à la forme et quant au fond du conseil
d'état qu'il ya même menace
d'inconstitutionnalité de certaines
parties du projet finalement aujourd'hui
il ya que la république en marche même
si en plus ça se fracturent même dans la
république est en marche c'est que l'abe
la république en marche comme une petite
secte là qui dirige le gouvernement et
qu'il veut un peu cette réforme au
forceps face à face à tout le pays face
à toutes les forces politiques à la
majorité des organisations syndicales et
à l'opinion des français
le texte arrive arrivait justement dans
l'hémicycle 17 février d'ici là quelles
sont les actions que vous comptez mener
poursuivre justement pour faire barrage
à cette réforme les retraites
alors évidemment il ya toujours la grève
reconductible qui a lieu quand même
encore dans plusieurs secteurs dans les
ports chez les éboueurs etc
mais il ya aussi l'idée de faire des
journées d'action chaque semaine comme
on en fait aujourd'hui avec appel à la
grève générale à la grève
interprofessionnelle de tout toutes les
catégories avec descendent dans la rue
et puis multiplication des initiatives
alors on l'a vu il ya eu les descentes
aux flambeaux
il ya eu un happening encore hier des
fonctionnaires et puis continuer à
expliquer a expliqué partout le danger
de cette réforme qui contrairement à ce
que dit madame ndiaye n'est pas au
service des français
bien au contraire qui va faire que tout
le monde va travailler plus plus
longtemps
et pour des pensions moindres avec le
risque d'avoir une société où on doit
choisir entre être des vieillards au
travail ou des retraités pauvres et
c'est cette société-là dont personne ne
veut et qu'on va continuer à se battre
contre ça et il ya toujours des marches
de lutte dont il ya toujours des marches
de victoire alors il ya un bras de fer
donc auquel on assiste aujourd'hui entre
les manifestants les opposants cette
réforme le gouvernement
ce bras de fer comment est-ce que vous
la présentez parce qu'on a là on a le
sentiment finalement qui a une
une course contre la montre qui est joué
combien de temps les manifestants pour
pouvoir tenir dans le cadre de ces
manifestations parce que bon voilà il
faut pouvoir manifester aussi ça fait
quand même quelques temps que cela dure
oui alors évidemment c'est un
gouvernement qui sait qu'il peut pas
convaincre la bataille de l'opinion il a
perdu dès le début il sait que l'immense
majorité des français non seulement et
contre son projet et en plus soutient la
grève donc la seule sa seule arme c'est
d'essayer d'écraser les gens par an nous
asphyxier financièrement un épais ya
zéro euro pour les grévistes on l'a vu
nous nous asphyxier financièrement en
refusant d'écouter en avançant comme un
bulldozer en dix ans de façon moi j'ai
la majorité parlementaire
j'en ai rien à cirer j'avance et et ce
sera décidé c'est la brutalité
en même temps cette désespérance va ne
prend pas parce que les gens ils
continuent à se battre
si la pelouse il ya match et aujourd'hui
le match continue héhéhé
et on voit bien que les gens ne se
désespère pas on a déjà connu de ceux
chirac par exemple qui avait retiré un
projet qui était déjà voter voter en 49
3 à l'époque le cpa en 2000 en 2006 qui
était déjà voté ils ont retiré
donc nous on va pas s'arrêter parce
qu'il nous dise bon ben maintenant c'est
l'auteur du parlement et on arrête les
manifestations non il ne sifflera pas la
fin du match et la fin de la récré o
continuera à se battre
et si cette réforme passe définitivement
le scénario possible que vous dire enfin
je veux dire un moment donné on s'est
battu tout au long du xxème siècle n'a
eu dé régression terrible qui est
lui-même l'occupation et a eu des castes
sociales considérables
et puis la classe ouvrière à la
continuer à se battre elle est revenue
sur le terrain c'est nous qui sommes la
majorité de la population les
travailleurs c'est nous qui créons
toutes ses richesses et on le démontre
d'ailleurs pendant la grève parce que
quand on s'arrête de travailler le pays
s'appauvrit
donc c'est nous qui sommes là là le sel
de la terre est là et la richesse du
monde donc il faut qu'on continue à se
faire entendre qu'on prenne conscience
de notre force et qu'on continue à se
faire entendre
on va continuer à se faire entendre
avant le vote on va continuer à se faire
entendre pendant les débats pour
continuer à les faire reculer et on va
continuer à se faire entendre tout le
long
aujourd'hui la cgt et y compris avec
l'intersyndicale construit à calendrier
de lutte qui ne s'arrête pas ni au débat
parlementaire ni aux municipales notre
agenda ce n'est pas celui-là
notre agenda c'est celui de l'intérêt
des travailleurs dont continuera à se
battre pour beaucoup mathieu guertin
pour avoir accepté notre invitation je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire du
syndicat cgt cheminots de versailles
merci merci